good morning everyone and welcome to the
24th annual Chicago Tribune printers
wrote book there my name is Michael gays
on and on the communications manager for
the Chicago Tribune and we'd like to
thank all of you for helping to support
Chicago Tribune's commitment to literacy
and we'd also like to thank the sponsor
of today's program the freedom museum
which is located at the base of the
historic Tribune Tower in downtown
Chicago and it's also the only museum in
the country that is dedicated to freedom
and the First Amendment you'd like more
information about the museum you can go
online at Freedom Museum us today's
session will be broadcast live by c-span
to his book TV and we ask that during
the Q&A toward the end of the session
that you use the microphones provided in
the center of the room so that our home
viewing audience can hear your questions
and now with that I'd like to introduce
the moderator for today's session bit
men when the author of spilling Buddha's
dinner
thank you so much and thank you for
being here today
I'm going to introduce Deborah Rodriguez
and Lily Capel and then generate a few
questions and then we'll open it up to
your questions
Deborah Rodriguez is the author with
Christian Olsen of the New York Times
bestseller Coble beauty school published
last year by Random House Rodriguez has
been a hair dresser since 1979
and in 2002 went to Afghanistan as part
of a humanitarian aid group there with
assistance from corporate sponsors
she helped develop and open the Kabul
beauty school aimed at helping Afghan
women the lucrative and empowering
careers in a society that offers very
few opportunities for women this
remarkable story along with the riveting
stories of Afghan women Rodriguez meets
and her own personal trials with love
and relationships come together to
create an irresistible read that is at
once heartbreaking and humorous Lily
Koppel a writer at the New York Times is
the author of the red leather diary
reclaiming a life through the pages of a
lost Journal recently published by
Harper a few years ago Capel came across
stacks of old steamer trunks that had
been languishing in the basement of her
building in New York of the many
treasures she rescued from the dumpster
the most precious turned out to be the
early 1930s era Diary of Florence
Wolfson a brilliant and passionate young
woman who kept a faithful account of her
days from ages 14 to 19 compiled manage
to drag down Florence Wolfson still
living a style at age 90 and reunite her
with her diary in this captivating book
which Booklist described as a
spellbinding glimpse into a vanished era
cofell retells the heady years of
Florence's youth including her
relationships with men and women her
literary ambitions and her struggle to
figure out who she wants to be so Debra
and Lily's first thank you for being
here and could you please talk about the
background of your books and how they
came to be yes I'm a hairdresser
since I was 16 actually and as most
hairdressers do we go to war zones to do
hair so I actually I started training
with disaster relief hairdresser of
about 20-some years and as many people I
was in my 40s a little bit bored with
what I was doing felt like I should be
doing more and I started doing what was
called vacation with a purpose so I
started raising money to go to like
India and put a well in and then I
started training with disaster relief at
that time right after my training 9/11
happened so I was deployed out to Ground
Zero and I worked there for two weeks
and that same organization then decided
to go to Afghanistan and do medical
clinics as a hairdresser I did not
actually have a place in the team but I
begged and begged and begged and I look
at their hair and begged some more and
they finally made me pay quite a bit of
money but allowed me to go with their
team which is uh an amazing experience
but because I was a hairdresser and
absolutely useless to this very very
professional medical team I did laundry
and I was smart enough to bring my
scissors along as every hairdresser does
you bring scissors and gel and you know
things that you do need in a war zone
along with my steel toed shoes and I
went and I set up shop an announcement
was made you know we have so-and-so over
here who's a dentist and so-and-so over
here is a physical therapist and and we
have a nurse and we have all these very
very amazing people and then we have on
yeah Debbie the hairdresser and funny
thing was the crowd went wild
I mean well if you saw their hair
honestly you would know why and so they
had been making this trek over the
Khyber Pass to Pakistan to get
highlights now when you looked at the
highlights and they were having Bionic
lights every time they get a haircut and
they were doing it was it really was a
disaster I'm telling
you don't think about hairdressing in a
war zone but really you're still women
women are women or women and they still
want to be beautiful and now you've got
missionaries mercenaries in the
broken-hearted there and so they also
need their hair done too so I set up
shop we didn't have phones with
walkie-talkies and only those who could
afford one and batteries actually could
have them and I didn't have one so I put
up a little sign in a hotel saying the
one and only hotel with all these like
mercenary men there and I said you know
doing here down in the basement and
people just started showing up and I
started that's how I started and started
hearing the loads of of Afghan hair and
started to think you know this is odd
I've never actually been in a country
where you couldn't get a good haircut
even some of the countries I'd been to
they weren't great salons but they still
could get it they could still get their
hair done and so I started to you know
just think about it well you know the
Taliban did put it underground it was
illegal to have their hair done it was
illegal to wear makeup fingernail polish
- nail polish you know all of this was
illegal along with kite-flying and you
know white shoes and so I started going
into the beauty shops I found one only
to realize that they had completely lost
their skills they had absolutely no
tools nothing
they had scissors about the size of
hedge clippers they were using perm
solution that was seven years old okay
all you women who have had perms and men
too but you know you wrap the perm they
were using sticks which is not that
uncommon but they were using these six
in their rep and the perm and then they
put the perm solution on the woman
grabbed her Berk off the hook put it on
and left I'm thinking okay wait a minute
don't you need to check this now the
place is about the size of a large
bathroom I mean there was no running
water there are no electricity and I
said should she be checking this no she
lets it dry okay well so obviously they
had that in Bleach so we had a lot of
black blonde and orange fuzzy hair so
that was when I thought you know you
need to teach them to fish versus give
them a fish and that's kind of how the
school got started my book came into
being the red leather diary when I was
22 I just moved to New York from Chicago
like any young person who moved to the
big city I was searching for love and
meaning in my own life in a good story I
had just landed a job at the New York
Times working as a Metro clerk during
the day which meant I was assisting
editors making calls Xeroxes helping
them coordinate breaking news while at
night I had started reporting and
getting my name into the paper by
reporting on celebrities and going out
to red-carpet events and holding my
little tape recorder and interviewing
Clint Eastwood Lindsay Lohan Shirley
MacLaine who tried to convince me of a
past life but for a young person like I
said really looking for a connection in
life that this was not enough and the
connection came in a very unexpected way
one morning I was late for work and I
came outside of my apartment building
and there in front of this great old
Upper West New York a New York apartment
building was a dumpster and half of the
dumpster was one side was collapsed so
you could see at a glance that there
were about 50 old steamer trunks and
imagine like a set out of Titanic but in
New York City and each was plastered
with a vintage travel label from Paris
London Monaco I remember one sticker
they really intrigued me was property of
the anne frank diary hotel in amsterdam
and despite being dressed and late for
work and you know i had to get there
because if there was a fire going on i
had to dispatch reporters or
and crime-scene under investigation but
this to me just look like an absolute
message in a bottle and I knew that all
of these trunks would have stories to
tell so I literally grabbed the
dumpsters grimy edge pulled myself on
top of this shifting maze and wondered
when I'd had my last tetanus shot as I
balanced the cross in my ballet flats
but started excavating these trunks and
there was an old flapper dress that
emerged from this virtual urban
shipwreck in a gorgeous old coat from
Bergdorf's with a single bakelite button
and old scalloped edge black-and-white
photographs and it was just this whiff
of another era of how women and men
lived in the 20s and 30s in New York
there was a whole collection of vintage
handbags still with their little match
boxes and notes you know get piano tuned
carpets down pick up bra from Saks but
um what really emerged from this chaos
was this crumbling red leather diary
kept by a young woman named Florence
Wolfson between the ages of 14 and 19
between 1929 in 1934 and in fact the
diary itself looks just like the book
cover and I brought it home that evening
and I sat down on my bed and kind of
held my breath as I unlatched this diary
and was just brought into this young
woman's world into his world of theater
in art and literature and a young person
really filling herself with all of these
things to survive and she was really
different from young women today and
that she was really the star of her own
show and as she was writing this diary
she was really finding out who she was
and growing as a person and it might
have been different if the young woman
was not an artist in a writer but she
was so the book was really her book and
it was written with great literary Flair
it 15 she was working on a novel she
obsessed with the famous avant-garde
stage actress evil a galleon who she
came to know she had jumps on horseback
through Central Park playing tennis
reading Baudelaire Jane Austen working
on a play on words worth and all along I
thought first this is a nice portrait of
a Jewish daughter growing up the
daughter of two Russian immigrants but
Florence proved more adventurous I
stumbled upon an entry slept with pearl
I realized this young woman really
didn't put any borders on herself and
was a complete nonconformist in a much
more conservative time it was the
depression and you know she was really
defined the conventions of the time and
of her parents but it was really a
portrait of a young woman searching for
love and meaning in her life and how she
would make her mark on the world and I
had the diary for three years and it was
just this magical object that I had
found a fairy tale that I had stumbled
into down the rabbit hole and one day I
get a chance call from a private
investigator and he had written read one
of my articles in the New York Times
about Manhattan's last typewriter
repairman also a lover of old New York
he wanted to reach out to me and I ended
up sharing the diary with him he's like
a character out of a pulp 1930s mystery
novel literally wears a trench coat the
first time we met for lunch
pulled a magnifying glass out of his
lapel so in many respects I was just
sitting and watching this story write
itself before my eyes and we had just
stumbled into this role as his
protagonist and went many ways in my own
film but he thought he could find
Florence's air as well by searching New
York cities birth records and using his
collection of vintage telephone books
that goes back to the early 20th century
he led me to Florence how it a nine year
old woman living in Pompano Beach
Florida
with her husband of 67 years one of her
many admirers from the diary who she had
met at his parents Catskills hotel named
Spring Lake picture dirty dancing but in
the 1930s and I called Florence up one
day nervous but excited wondering if I
had perhaps violated her privacy these
were her innermost thoughts but I hadn't
and she answered with his voice of this
great old stage actress and she just
said oh my god this is incredible
did you know I was a writer you know and
I told her I was too and she said I have
to meet you
and I had to meet her too and so a month
later I took up a train to Connecticut
where she lives during the summer with
her crumbling book and reunited her with
her diary and it was really this
incredible moment which she writes about
in the forward to the book which is how
does one feel when a forgotten chunk of
their life is handed back to them and
she said it stopped my heart for a
moment and it's become this virtual
Fountain of Youth for her and in turn
really changed my life allowing me to
write my first book but really able to
just show the significance I believe of
all of our lives and to piece together
this existence it was literally headed
for the trash through the 75 year old
diary
[Applause]
these books are both extraordinary
portraits of women whose lives might you
know have been overlooked how to do not
found them and so I'm curious to know to
what extent you identify with these
women the women of Kabul in Deborah's
case is Florence Wolfson in Lily's case
how you identify with these women and
how you feel your lives have changed
your lives the perspectives have changed
as a result of your experiences and
writing about them I wasn't a abuse of
marriage for five years I kept saying
that I had my own Taliban in my living
room and I was watching my last name is
Rodriguez out of spite
I kept his last name to torture him the
rest of his life because everybody
thinks I'm Latino but I I had my own
Taliban and I remember watching these
women we all saw it on TV where they put
them in that white toyota truck and they
bring them out into the stadium they
take them in their blue burkas they put
them down on their knees and shoot them
and I'm watching this I'm so moved I
kind of put myself away in my own little
room my own little sanctuary and I
remember thinking to myself I didn't
have freedoms either anybody in an
abusive situation knows when your
freedoms are taken away from you and I
felt the same way and I kept I kept
thinking that I can I understand how
they feel I kept wondering I wonder if I
feel anything like they do and somehow I
knew I had to go to Afghanistan and I
remember the last words that he spoke to
me I was still married and he said I
hope you die
can ascend and I said you know what
honest I would rather die in Afghanistan
than spend one more day with you and I
basically walked out of the house shut
the door and I didn't return and when I
got to Afghanistan and I thought I had
problems oh come on I mean talk about
feel embarrassed at how you how pathetic
you felt you know I felt so sorry for
myself oh poor me poor me but these
women had some serious issues I mean not
only had they been stuck in their house
for some of them eight years had not
even gotten out they weren't able to
learn how to read and write every woman
today I'm this is still the case
okay this they have not progressed I
mean you want to think they have we have
not liberated Afghanistan by the way and
every woman has a man in charge of their
life whether it's a younger or older
brother a husband a father an uncle a
grandfather who can at any moment say
you will not or you will do this in this
story you will give me your money you
will marry this man you will do whatever
I tell you to do and I saw these women
the one thing that I saw that I think
captivated me from the very moment I set
my eyes on them was the fact they didn't
feel sorry for themselves they had this
courage in this strength and even in all
I mean I couldn't even comprehend I
remember one woman telling me how her
and her sister were chained to their bed
or chained - it wasn't actually a bed it
was like a railing
they were chained to it because they
didn't want them to leave the house who
are afraid that they were going to get
boyfriend's they chained them come on
that's that's just sick and having a
young woman at 12 mariya a 50 year old
man this is not a good thing and so I
kept watching how these women were not
feeling sorry for them
yes they did have post-traumatic stress
they still do they still have
dysfunctional behavior but don't we all
and the thing is is I watch them and
they gave me the strength to not feel
sorry for myself not to wallow in oh
poor Debbie poor Debbie but to move past
it and they gave me the strength to
actually walk out of my marriage and I
there was times I can't say that
Afghanistan was easy it was sometimes
the most hard frustrating mind-boggling
experience but the time you figure out
you get good Afghanistan and get the
people and understand the culture maybe
understand the language a bit it's like
layers of an onion you pull it back
there's another layer and you think okay
where have I been
how did I miss this and I learned from I
learned a couple things number one we
will really never understand that
culture it's so old it's so ancient and
we got to take I mean I made so many
full pause there we got to take our
mindset of what needs to be in
Afghanistan it's their country they have
a way of doing things and we kind of got
to step back give them tools and then
step back and let them build their
country
I've learned so much from my mistakes
I've learned so much from the successes
I've learned so much from the women and
how to be strong in your worst situation
and they're amazing people there is
strong and as harsh and as rugged as
their terrain it's it's amazing place
and I just feel so honored that I had
this moment to glimpse into their lives
so Florence really did change my life
and I remember that first night when I
was reading the diary and I was trying
to imagine what she might have looked
like who was Florence Wolfson who was
this young woman who had filled this
Diaries worn pages with over 2,000
trees entries like stuffed myself with
Mozart and Beethoven I feel like a ripe
apricot
I'm dizzy with the exotic and I thought
in our world of BlackBerry's and iPhones
I mean how many young people are filling
themselves with art and music who really
have a strong sense in mind of who they
want to be and are always expanding that
sense of self I stumbled upon the entry
five hours of tennis and glorious
happiness all I want is someone to love
I feel incomplete this was an incredibly
self-reflective young woman but also
very external she would later remind me
she had a literary salon when she was a
19 year old graduate student at Columbia
that the poet's Delmore Schwartz and
John Berryman were part of when she was
at Hunter she was the editor-in-chief of
their literary magazine called echo on
her staff was joy David men who would go
on to marry CS Lewis their marriage
chronicled in the movie Shadowlands with
Debra Winger and Anthony Hopkins also
Belle Kaufman the granddaughter of
Shalom Aleichem who was also the
best-selling author of up the down
staircase and Florence Wolfson was
really a young woman who wanted to be
known who dreamed of having a literary
career who wrote it 15 and working on a
novel you didn't know I was working on
one did you but what adolescent is an
adolescent without a novel and here I
was holding her red leather book and I
just had to say how true Florence he
were here were just these authentic
feelings which this starry-eyed 16 year
old who lived more like a 20 year old
with just independence who hardly felt
her parents presence in her life had
written down her thoughts which he
thought no nobody would ever find now of
course I did find Florence in one of the
most interesting things about meeting
her was I had read this diary as if it
was a personal letter to me this
newspaper clipping that I
started to describe had fallen out of
the diaries pages on it was her picture
she was platinum blonde in fact he dyed
her hair from sneaking peroxide from her
father's medical office which was in
their apartment I'm not sure if that's a
good thing mother was a Couture dress
maker but both very fearless and
immigrants who'd really established
themselves in New York after the turn of
the century and I from first thing that
picture of Florence and these
intelligent longing eyes I just felt
like I knew this young woman and this
young woman of the 30s in me today could
have been the same person in many ways
but we were separated by three-quarters
of a century and what was so interesting
about meeting Florence was when the
Diary finish is just about to turn 19
and here I meant this 90 year old woman
with no space in between so I was able
to see a nine-year-old really as her
teenage self as this young woman who is
striving in ambitious and had really big
dreams in mind and one of the
bittersweet moments about meeting her
was that she turned to me and she said
you know from reading about that young
woman in the Diaries pages how did I end
up living this ordinary life and I think
like so many people she had started out
you know with a vision of her life in
mind and it somehow felt like she had
lost herself along the way that she
really knew how she was back then but
that had gotten married and had kids
nothing to argue with but wasn't exactly
where she had anticipating being when
she was that age but the more we
excavated her life and the original
Times article that I wrote about her was
called speak memory and this is really
what the process of writing this book
was was just peeling back the layers of
time and revealing her life from the 30s
Florence turned to me and she said you
know you've brought back my life and I
told her will you
back mine too I mean I think this is
speaks to why all of us read and just
our curiosity in life and why we want to
expand our horizons is to learn about
other people and who they are in the way
I was able to when I met Florence bring
back that 14 year old girl to the 9 year
old woman and let the two meet and she's
really provided me with an incredible
perspective on life she's really the
enduring woman of the diary in that she
said go for it she said that's what she
thought her younger self would have said
I don't know many nine year olds who
would speak so matter-of-factly about
sex about their love affairs and just
about who they set out to become in who
they ended up becoming with such honesty
so we read these books we become so
attached to the stories of Florence and
the women in the beauty school in Kabul
and part of the reason why that happens
is because the writing is so clear and
it's so it's a beautifully done that
their stories just come to life and so
I'm curious to know if about your
process of writing nonfiction genre that
is amorphous it's hard to pin down how
do you think about your books as memoir
versus journalism and were there any
particular challenges you dealt with in
the writing process I never I'm a
hairdresser I never said I know and I
never set out to write a book I was
trying to make a living and Holland
Michigan being a hairdresser and I would
I would leave my my clients who had
horrid roots by the time I came back and
I'd be gone for you know first time one
month the second time two months I
stretched it to three months they really
hated me and I needed to keep my
customers because I had you know bills
to pay so I started writing these really
lengthy emails every day I would at the
end of the day I would write down
everything
like just trigger points like what
happened and then I'd sit down when we
had electricity and I would literally
just make these massive emails and I
would send them out and I didn't want I
really wanted to bring my customers and
my friends into my world so that they
understood that like I really needed
them to be my customers when I came back
so I could pay my bills and that was
really kind of how it started but I
never I never saved any of these I just
sent them off and you know went on with
my day and I came back maybe it was
about a year two years into this whole
Afghan process and my one of my very
good friends who is in the book we call
it a 2 meter woman she was 66 foot
something and she was painting the salon
for me and but she she had taken all my
emails and she I don't spellcheck
anything and I did I literally said
there's never a capital letter there's
never periods it's just one giant sand
and I would just send it hood I would
just be typing away and not paying
attention to anything and my English
teacher would it laughs still that there
I have a book but that is why we have
editors but of so they she seek out my
my emails she gotten a law she's spell
checked them
she except a little pictures she put
them in a folder in book form she goes
Debbie here's your book don't stop
writing I'm like I'm not a writer she
goes you're a storyteller
do not stop telling your stories because
you bring us into a world that we don't
know so at that point um that's when
someone introduced me to blogging so
then I began to blog because you know my
emails are just so large and that way I
could add pictures and that's what I
started doing and I started realizing
when I read through that that a book she
gave me I'm like oh I forgot about that
oh I forgot about that and I realized
how many things I had actually forgotten
and so at that point I decided you know
what it's not about them anymore because
now I had actually picked up to move
Cabo's I didn't need to keep my
customers but I needed to not forget and
that's what I was worried about that I
would forget and so that's how that's
how it happened and nonfiction is is
interesting because you forget you it's
really funny because you meet people my
son just got married and you know so
what does he give the in-laws is the
book first so now you know and I keep
going I quit smoking really I quit
smoking and you know it's like you
forget you tell really at the time
you're like into the moment and you're
telling personal things and you forget
that the world knows like things that
you think huh if I thought about that I
might not have said it but you're just
all of a sudden your life is just being
put on paper and it feels okay and then
you realize that you know millions of
people are like reading about your sex
life or you know I mean my mom didn't
know I smoke I don't smoke anymore by
the way I did quit but it's like when
all of a sudden that first page came out
and I looked at the book and I read it
and I thought oh my god my mother's
going to know I smoked and so it is a
very unusual we changed the names of the
girls we've had some issues with the
identity of the women the one thing was
very important an issue that I do like
to just bring to in 2005 women in
Afghanistan could speak their mind they
could work as journalists they could
sing they could do the things that we
thought that we were going there to do
it's 2008 they're killing the
journalists they're stabbing them at
their door there's a thing like American
Idol this thing called Star Search
Afghan star the third runner-up was a
woman which was fabulous she is in
hiding now
so things have gone backwards to an
extensive point
to a point that it's really really scary
to be a woman in Afghanistan now and
where we were had made such amazing
progress in 2005 where the girls are so
excited to tell their story and so
excited they wanted to use a real name
now there now it's like you know people
are trying to punish them for telling
their story and it's very frightening
but it's a way that the land is going
now and you know I think a lot of people
don't realize that how bad it's gotten
from 2006 to 2008 um of course when I
found the diary I already thought it was
a work of art this was the book of this
young woman and my intention was to
return it to Florence and I was just
honored to be brought into her world
into a very different city a city that
she really had ownership over that she
would ride the double-decker bus and
stare into the 5th Avenue apartment
buildings like they were a little
theatrical performance put on just for
her theatre every night when it was
affordable and just this very rich world
when I met Florence she as I told you
said that she was a writer which I knew
from reading the Diaries pages and she
has a real flair for the dramatic and
she knew that I wrote for the New York
Times and she thought isn't this just an
incredible story and of course I thought
it was and so this grew into an article
and my editor at Harpers stumbled upon
the article she lives in the
neighborhood visited the building and
called me up and she said I want to
write read more and of course I had
research piled up to here from going in
excavating Florence's College Archives
in these lines of women with Marcel's
hair and matching v-necks provided by
the photographer names like pearls
Beatrice's Ethel's Gertrude's
Florence's
and I just thought what happened to you
all all these very Stern determined
faces the daughters of immigrants and I
wanted to know what had happened to them
later in life and so the book really
grew out of this diary
it's an amalgam of interviews a memoir
of me finding the diary finding Florence
Florence's world in a nine year old
woman reflecting on the course of her
life and it was really time travel back
to the 30s and Florence and I both
reread the diary and the book is
interspersed with her diary entries so
that each reader really feels like
they're discovering this journal in this
life and the challenge with Florence was
only she turned to me and she said but
I'm not a celebrity I'm not a public
figure and that was really the challenge
to overcome but the one that I thought
was so important which was just the
significance of all of our lives and
that it really didn't matter that she
wasn't a celebrity and wasn't famous she
sailed to Europe in 1936 and traveled
from London to Paris to Rome where she
embarked on a love affair with an
Italian count named Filippo Kenna let
ego dent a duster Rollo who composed
love verses to her which were later
published it was an adventure but also a
very serious and important reflection on
the stories that all of us have to tell
and we always say you know well everyone
has a novel in them well here was a life
which would have otherwise been lost but
was brought to life in Florence now says
she's one of the luckiest women in the
world and is really having this
Renaissance later in life and just being
discovered for being her very true in
authentic self
and now question some of the audience
don't be shy could you please if you
could step up to the microphone in the
center thank you I wanted to ask Deborah
Rodriguez how would you explain the
changes happening in Afghanistan from
2005 to 2008 well outside of the fact
that I'm a hairdresser not like a
political analyst I can kind of just
tell you what I saw there is a there
seems to be a lot of money and raping a
conflict area basically there is I think
I read an email from my girlfriend who's
still there and I the one of the big
problems is embassies are not there
they're reinventing the wheel every day
they're not working as a team with their
projects USAID is is horrible for this
organizations like NGOs nongovernmental
agencies they're not coordinating so
it's like how many schools can you build
Casillas seems like like our military
loves to build schools you can get
funding to build schools
there's no teachers you can build a
hospital hello
there's no doctors so this is what's
happening is there's this an enormous
amount of waste with the money my
girlfriend works with refugees right and
she's she literally wrote an email and
you could see her weeping in it she
works with refugees where they said you
can't live here anymore you got to go
over here and they put them in this
barren field right and so a USAID was
funding a woman's Jirga which is a
woman's meeting for seven hundred
thousand dollars for two days two days
she goes I have people that haven't
eaten for two days okay so now we've got
a few angry afghans
and rightfully so because they see very
very well
some people are making $1,500 a day
that's a lot of money when that's their
income for a year and they're living
very very high I mean you know when
you're there you have a cook you have a
cleaner you have all these things but
the thing is is the money isn't going to
the right places so now you've got
poppies what else are they going to grow
give an alternative there is no
alternative at this point there's
poppies there's mafia there's criminal
activity
you got the insurgency of the Taliban
you have got just people who are tired
of watching the foreigners live high on
the hog and the Afghans are starving
did you realize the winter was so harsh
at one point there was over a thousand
people just froze to death their their
their sheep their goats their everything
we're freezing they're starving there's
no food they can't get wheat Pakistan
has cut off the borders and is only
allowing a portion of wheat to come in
they're robbing the wheat markets
they're hungry they're angry they see
six years of liberation only coming to
the fact there's more suicide bombings
every day than ever
there's roadside bombs suicide bombs
they're bombing there they're inserting
bombs into donkeys we didn't have this
before they didn't have this before
they're not making any money the men are
sitting and they're not able to feed
their family so what did happen I don't
know something didn't go right how I
don't know what the answer is either
because it's so far the other way it's
so bad now that really honest I I pray
for the country every day I am very very
worried and so are the Afghans and so
most of the foreigners that are working
there
gotten bad patient system in place where
the children going to yes they are going
to school but the thing is is you
realize there's no teachers the teachers
are getting paid $40 a month they can't
afford to teach they could work as a
cleaning lady somewhere for a hundred to
one hundred and fifty dollars a month
but the teachers aren't educated they
are not school to teach you know what I
mean they grab all these girls and they
put them to school but there's no proper
teachers because there's no system for
that yet you know the government
corruption it's an enormous amount of
corruption from the very top to the very
bottom i I know of a situation where a
school was so-called funded right the
the person who was funding the school
took the money and when the the person
came to see his school that he built
they brought him to pay paid another
they paid to borrow another school oh
this is your school and these are all
your students and it wasn't he just
pocketed the money I mean it's just
corruption there's so much corruption
but we have not we have not liberated
Afghanistan
that's very clear yes thank you any
other questions please put it down low
just for Debbie are you still doing here
in Holland I know I actually I moved to
California and the weather's really nice
and I'm there now I basically been doing
my book tour and I don't have a license
in California so they won't what I do
here on the side but don't tell anybody
and you can never get away from doing
here but I'm actually working on another
book right now so is it a sequel er it's
about Afghanistan there's a lot of
trafficking of women through the guise
of marriage
kind of on long that line and Lily are
you also working another book I am
working on another book one of the
things that was really meaningful to me
about writing the red leather diary was
Florence's daughter's reaction to the
book both are in their 60s she also has
granddaughters and great-grandchildren
and her daughters not only you know did
they find out things about their mother
that they had never known her affairs as
both men and women and just how
passionate she was as a young writer
they said that they had just learned so
much about her from reading the book
just seeing her not is their mother but
is this person with this whole other
life before they were part of the
picture and this really is made me think
recently and just look at my mother in a
different way and that's the question
I'm going to be probing really how do we
see our mothers and do we really know
them do we know them how we know our
friends and I'm going to be telling her
story which starts in World War two and
ends up in Newport Rhode Island where
her father was the physician to JFK at
the summer White House and it's this
young woman's coming of age her years at
Pembroke and going to San Francisco for
the summer of love wonderful and a quick
follow-up question about Florence Wilson
you mentioned that she would she said
that she didn't know how she had ended
up living in ordinary life after keeping
this diary that was full of you know
affairs and a glamour how did that
happen what what happened to - this is a
woman who is a passionate writer writer
I mean isn't yeah Farris and you know
glamour but I mean she was really a rare
combination of both beauty and intellect
she remembered from her literary salon
bending down to light the fireplace in
her parents apartment as her
guess Delmore Schwartz and John Berryman
were debating the poetics of Aristotle
and st. Thomas Aquinas and as she bent
down to unpin her long blonde hair let
it cascade down and so she really was
aware of both being as sharp as a whip
intellectually but also her powers of
seduction but how did this happen well
Florence's parents both Russian Jewish
immigrants really wanted her to sew up
her life as fast as possible this summer
there were trips to the Catskills and
they wanted her to get married and marry
a nice doctor and you know just make
herself secure that was enough for them
but for her she wanted this whole other
dimension out of life which was one of
art and beauty and in the 1940s after
she got married she did have a stint
writing feminist Tinch articles for big
magazines at the time that published all
of the great writers Upton Sinclair's
and Claire Sinclair Lewis like Good
Housekeeping Ladies Home Journal
Cosmopolitan articles such as how to
behave in public without an escort or
how to quarrel with your husband but
Florence in a way gave in to the
conventions of her time and her parents
but you know there was always that
internal searching voice within her that
knew that she wanted to do more and I
think that's really the beauty of the
story of the red leather diary which is
that her words and her just her passion
and ambition has come full circle to her
and this incredibly serendipitous way
through another young writer late in her
life and it is really just rewritten the
end of her life she turned to me and she
said my life is a tragedy she's very
dramatic I said no it wasn't Florence
but she said but now it's a romantic
comedy
and she recently got a laptop and is
thinking about writing again and keeping
a diary even though she she said she's
actually just happy breathing and
feeling more alive than she has in years
and she's about to celebrate her 93rd
birthday in August and suddenly she's
become this Authority people are asking
her opinion on things I mean this is
like Florence jokes it's like sexy
Tuesdays with Maurey but it's real and I
think that's an important thing to
remember about the red leather diaries
this store is larger than the book and
it's about these two people who
connected and everybody who connects
with its message which is about the
significance of all of our lives these
are both extraordinary portraits and
extraordinary women so thank you both
for being here and sharing these stories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
I always looking for like history
biography and public affairs you're
watching book TV on c-span 2 this
weekend were live from the printers Row
Book Fair in Chicago
coming up next Marc Bouwer line author
of the dumbest generation and Rob Walker
on buying in and then a panel featuring
David Mendel author of Obama and Blake
Dvorak of RealClearPolitics calm